[Musique]
bonsoir mes amis au droit
au bail d'offres au mot d'ordre au mali
que monter tu es bien pressé nounours
patron je crois que mes amis m'ont
laissé un peu de poudre a tout de suite
à je
comprends gros gourmand
nicolas se veut faire du bien la
connaître au plus mal au coeur ollo on a
mal au corps du
pauvre peuple mais pourquoi
monique tout le poutine ou le petit coin
j'ai maintenant si on veut pas être
malade on doit voir ce médicament
si vous m'aviez laisser un peu de poudre
vous ne sauriez pas malade la prochaine
fois nous n'oublierons pas neuf mais si
tu fais un peu de médicaments de gêne
pas ollo merci mais moi qui anono pas ma
grande
les enfants c'est vous qui allez boire
comme des grands et si vous êtes sages
tu nous fais une surprise potter nous
verrons je compte jusqu'à 3
le jeu ne regarde pas
oh
[Musique]
u13
j'ai tout vu
bravo alors nous chantons une chanson
met en avant la musique
quand je passais par le bois le coucou
chantait
chabert et dans son joli chant faisait
coucou coucou coucou
mais moi je croyais qu'il disait au
public ou copient le coup et moi du coup
jugements sont veut sombre et moi du
coup jean en sauveur
et
il
dont je passais par le prêt le faucheur
ont cherché
dans son joli chant puzzle à quelle
chaleur en quelle chaleur schaller a
bien chalets et moi je croyais qu'ils
disaient en quel voleur à quel voleur et
moi du coup je mens son ressort et moi
du coup je mens chauvin
mange pas fait preuve de l'aidant qu'un
hara le chambon
canada et dans son joli son puzzle coin
et moi je croyais qu'ils disaient qu'ils
aillent au moins il est au point et moi
du coup france on veut sobre et moins du
coup je pense aux bains
il
ils se sont sauvés eux aussi
mais j'ai banni
alors vous allez mieux
vous voyez vous êtes thierry la jette à
la lueur
1 demain le petit
adam à nos noces
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il était bon ce putin mais la
patron nounours n'a pas mangé de toute
une pauvre gros nounours gourmand à laon
en route bonne nuit les enfants
avec bourg
[Musique]